welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Hilary man Leverett a senior fellow
at the Jackson Institute for Global
Affairs at Yale and CEO of Stratego a
political risk consultancy that focuses
on international energy and financial
markets she has served in the State
Department and at the National Security
Council at the White House during the
George HW Bush Clinton and George W Bush
administration's in the George W Bush
administration ms Leverett worked as the
director for iran afghanistan and
persian gulf affairs at the National
Security Council as Middle East
specialist on the security of States
policy planning staff and as political
advisor for Middle East and Central
Asian issues for the US mission to the
United Nations today we'll talk with
Professor Leverett about Iran and the
future of American power welcome
professor llevaron thank you for having
me you currently are working on a book
with your husband Flynt Leverett called
going to Tehran Iran and the future of
American power tell us a bit about it
and what's its premise well the going to
Tehran part of it takes on what i would
call many myths that maybe even most
Americans have about Iran both its
foreign policy and its domestic politics
so the going to check Iran is really to
go to take you to Tehran into the
decision making the thought process both
in terms of foreign policy and domestic
politics inside the Islamic Republic the
second piece of the title the merit and
the future of American power makes a
policy argument that if you go through
if you do a sober analysis of iran's
foreign policy strategy and a really
clear understanding of its domestic
politics
you come to the conclusion that the
United States Muse needs to deal with
the Islamic Republic as it is that it's
going to be an enduring political order
in the region for some time and that for
the United States to maintain if not
restore its credibility in the Middle
East it needs to have a fundamentally
more constructive relationship with the
Islamic Republic as it is and in order
in order for the United States to retain
its global power the United States must
have a more credible position in the
Middle East which the book makes this
part policy argument one of the only
ways the United States can do that today
is to have a more constructive
relationship with the Islamic Republic
of Iran why do you feel it's important
to write the book the coming back to my
first point that I think most of what
most Americans think they know about
Iran is wrong I think it's critically
important at this point in time to write
a book that takes on each of the myths
that we have about the Islamic Republic
in particular there's a there's a policy
reason to do so a broader reason to do
so which is that in the lead-up to the
invasion of Iraq in 2003 it took many
years for the American political dynamic
American political elites to get to the
position where not only the invasion of
Iraq was the decision to invade Iraq was
taken but with so much American
political elite buy-in from the opposing
political party the democratic political
party at the time within Congress among
academics even among the media there was
a there was a broad a broad-based buy
into to invade Iraq based on what we
found out later to be a lot of very
faulty and unquestioned assumptions
about about Iraqi politics about Iraqi
leadership rocks position in the Middle
East those same questions I think the
those questions and assumptions about
how we view the Islamic Republic of Iran
need to be taken now we need to question
our fundamental assumptions about the
Islamic Republic in a way that we did
not in the lead-up to the war in Iraq
because i think we are on a trajectory
toward conflict with the Islamic
Republic so two of the most important
examples I think we need to take on to
most important assumptions we need to
take on is first in terms of foreign
policy there is a widely held assumption
that Iran is an ideologically immature
irrational polity that cannot take
decisions based on its material state
national interests one one of the very
few American officials that had the
opportunity to deal with to negotiate
with Iranian officials because we don't
have a diplomatic relationship and
because of the antagonism between the
United States and the Islamic Republic
the US government essentially forbids
its diplomats from dealing with Iranian
officials so very few American officials
had had the opportunity to even speak to
Iranian officials so they don't really
have any first-hand information
understanding about Iran's strategic
dilemmas there their national security
concerns their legitimate interests
because of my work on Afghanistan I was
authorized to deal with my Iranian
counterparts on the narrow issue of
Afghanistan al Qaeda but it opened a
tremendous door for me in terms of
Iranian national security
decision-making thinking context so one
of the things the book will bring is
that perspective that very few Americans
have that Iranian diplomats and the
infrastructure the foreign policy and
national security infrastructure in Iran
can take and do take over and over again
decisions based on Iran's national
interest that we can deal with them in
terms of their national interest than
the other examples in terms of domestic
politics there's a widely held
assumption in the United States that
Iran is some sort of fragile political
order just waiting to collapse or
implode so there's a demonstration we
think this is evidence that the that the
government there is going to fall and it
will inaugurate some new political order
that inevitably will be more secular
more democratic and more pro-american I
take on a lot of those assumptions to
really make the argument that the
revolution the islamic revolution that
occurred in the late 1970s was a
fundamental turn in iran's identity it's
and its political order domestically and
that for 30 years the Iranians inside
Iran have really built a very stable
durable political order in a sense
analogous to what the
what happened in the people's republic
of china or even some of my iranian
colleagues would say like what happened
with the the revolution in France that
the revolution in iran was just as
important to the change in iran's
identity in its regional context and
that the United States needs to come to
terms with the fact that that political
order is going to be the political order
in Iran for for quite some time and just
as we came to terms with people's
republic of china and reoriented our
relationship with the People's Republic
of China fundamentally in the early
1970s when Nixon went to China that's
where the going to Tehran title comes
from that we need to fundamentally
reorient our relationship with the
Islamic Republic of Iran and not
necessarily that Obama needs to fly to
Tehran but we need to in terms of our
thinking about Iran really come to terms
with the reality of the Islamic Republic
what that means for how they act in
terms of their foreign policy and what
that means in terms of their domestic
political order why do you think we're
not doing that today and and why do
these myths perpetuate this is one of
the most surprising and interesting
aspects that I think I've I've I've come
across in writing the book and
researching the book I think it has less
to do about what goes on inside Iran
than it has to do with us here in the
United States both in terms of our
political culture political leads
academia medium and I think it comes it
could come down to maybe one idea in
particular this the idea of American
exceptionalism that we are we have these
big ideas from manifest destiny too many
of you know many other to the Cold War
many big ideas and that we that somehow
everybody would want to be like us and
people try to be like us and the
inevitable process of modernization will
transform countries to be like us if
they only have the chance this is
something that I think is really
ingrained in our political culture and
only when we're forced to or when we
have I think great statesmanship can we
really change that dynamic now with
Nixon
controversial president as he was the
opening to China really was a mark of
great statesmanship he took the decision
for the opening to China at a time when
we needed to get out of Vietnam we had
the super problem superpower conflict
with the Soviet Union and he saw the
United States as a power and relative
decline at the time economically
militarily politically we're in a
similar situation today and what I find
the most challenging aspect of the ideas
that I'm putting forward in the book is
can we can we have statesmanship akin to
what China Nixon did with China where we
realize we understand we come to terms
with the fact that the United States is
a power in relative decline and how do
we stop the hemorrhaging maintain our
position of credibility and power and
maybe even built on that we're not going
to be able to do it through military I
mean through political superiority or
hedge emoni or economic superiority or
hedge money we're trying to do it a bit
with millet with the military in Iraq
and Afghanistan but it's not going very
well we need to really have a
fundamentally different construct to
figure out how to come to terms with
regional important regional players
whether that's Turkey whether that's
Iran it's very difficult for us to do so
I think particularly because of our
political culture this idea of American
exceptionalism but also because of
engrained entrenched domestic interest
groups that I think are amplified in our
political system not only because of our
heritage and our history but because of
our relative security which makes at the
voice of interest groups as important as
they are in any context have even a
bigger voice in our domestic context so
we have both the Big Ideas issue
American exceptionalism and almost a
small ideas the interest groups coming
together in a very powerful way to
constrain the United States from taking
steps and opportunities that I think are
to me very obviously in the US interest
okay let's talk about the methodology
you you're using to write the book how
are you doing the research
well the first first piece of the the
research and what I'm trying to pull
together are a lot of my own experiences
drawing from my own experiences in
dealing with in talking to Iranian
officials both Iranian diplomats as well
as senior Iranian officials across the
political spectrum in Iran from the we
call them just for shorthand kind of the
Conservatives or the hardliners to the
more reformists and so-called moderates
a very simplistic kind of portrayal of
the political system there but
essentially just to give you an idea of
the range of contexts I think at a high
level throughout Iran that I've that I
developed starting with my official
negotiations with them and talks with
them over Afghanistan al Qaeda in the
wake of 911 starting with that but
developing it from 2001 to the present
so I've had nearly 10 years of working
on this consistently constantly over
time to really try to develop an
understanding of their security concerns
their decision-making and to really
bring that to really bring that into the
book as I as I mentioned one of the most
distorting aspects of the u.s. debate
about Iran is that we never hear the
either the official interpretation or
justification or idea about something
nor do we do we really hear from people
who support the Islamic Republic we hear
about various dissidents and people who
have had problems people have emigrated
but we never hear from the tens of
millions of Iranians who are still in
Iran and many of whom if not most of
whom support the Islamic Republic even
if they don't necessarily support the
person in President Ahmadinejad I would
argue that the vast majority still
support the idea of the Islamic Republic
let me give you an example of one of the
things that I found in doing just doing
the research and drawing on my personal
experiences no matter how many books
people read on Iran rarely does it come
out that the political in the political
system in Iran the president is
term-limited but this is something in my
discussions with Iranian officials that
would come out whether it was dealing
with President the issue of President
Ahmadinejad or before him president
taught to me who was a more of a
reformist figure seen as a little bit
more in line with Western ideas of
modernization in both cases Iranian
diplomats would talk about Iranian
officials from across the political
spectrum would talk about the national
interest for the Islamic Republic and if
someone would mention well but President
Ahmadinejad said this or president ought
to me said this there was all due
deference to their head of state but
there was a there was it was clear for
them and they would say it repeatedly
well yes he is important but the system
does not rest on one person whether it's
the president who is term-limited will
even the supreme leader that one of the
things that's interesting and important
about the system inside the Islamic
Republic almost like the system inside
China is that both the founding father
of the Islamic Republic Ayatollah
Khomeini as well as chairman mao in
China they both bequeathed to their
systems not not not into their countries
not a western-style democratic system
but a competitive political system that
endures beyond personalities so what I
try to bring from my personal experience
in talking to so many different Iranian
officials and people who live in Iran's
support the Islamic Republic is this
idea of the enduring nature of the
Islamic Republic regardless of who's
president so President Ahmadinejad's has
something that they don't like or we
don't like the the problem is contained
in that there will be people who will
challenge him the next time around in
the next election so the first thing I
do is I draw from from my contacts
across the across the spectrum in Iran
which i think is very unique it will be
a new unique contribution to the debate
the others the other is of course going
through our archival material from each
of the u.s. administration's dating back
to 19th from 1979 to document the number
of times and the depth of interaction
constructive interaction many cases
between the United States and the
Islamic Republic so one of the other
myths is well the Islamic Republic is so
radical so hostile to the United States
and in fact means the hostility towards
United States to legitimate its own
political order one of the ways that I'm
going about I think deconstructing that
that myth and rebutting that myth is to
go back and show how every US
administration reached out to the
Islamic Republic of Iran to cooperate
with it in some way whether it was
President Reagan's administration with
what we know about iran-contra
iran-contra scandal the first George
Bush administration reached out to the
Islamic Republic to get Iran's help to
secure the release of us hostage
hostages in lebanon the Clinton
administration cooperated in directly
with the Iranians to supply the Muslims
in Bosnia with weapons during the Balkan
conflict in the 1990s and of course the
the Bush administration that I worked
for cooperated with sought Iran's help
for Afghanistan and al-qaeda in each one
of these cases we go through the all the
archival material and you interview
people in each one of these cases of
cooperation it was the united states
that cut off the cooperation for reasons
that had nothing to do with iran for
reasons that had to do with our domestic
politics for the most part in each one
of these cases the Iranians delivered
not everything the United States asked
for but almost everything they delivered
a lot of what we asked for it was the
United States so that cut off each one
of these periods of engagement going
back to iran contra iran-contra failed
not because the Iranians didn't come
through but because of a constitutional
crisis here in the United States when
Reagan administration officials try to
divert the proceeds from selling weapons
to the Iranians to fund the Contras in
Nicaragua in contravention with with US
law so we've had this you know this
really messy situation on the US side
undermine cooperation throughout so
that's the other that's the other major
area I'll be drawing I'll be drawing on
I am very curious and listening to you
to know whether there are any gender
barriers when you're talking with
Iranian Iranian officials as a woman did
you have any difficulty I had no
difficulty once
ever it's i think that the inside the
islamic republic i think this is one of
the other myths that it's a misogynistic
political water i think this is really a
myth before the Islamic Revolution women
were able to of course walk the streets
without their hair covered and there was
this idea of kind of a liberal
atmosphere for women but in fact many
women couldn't really go to school or
hold senior government jobs or senior
jobs in business or the professions now
many of that was but most of that as
much of that was almost self selective
conservative families didn't really
weren't that interested in having women
particularly from villages and non-urban
areas having their daughters or their
wives go to university to mingle you
know to be with people the opposite sex
or to be in positions in the office
where they're you know they're
vulnerable innocence now of course many
women before the Islamic Republic was
created did benefit if they were in the
elite but if he weren't in the elite in
Iran if you're a woman and most of the
population were not elite you really had
a problem in terms of educational and
career advancement what the Islamic
Republic has done is really even the
field so while elite women of course
can't go out cover there's you have to
be covered in in the streets and in the
professions there is there the system
for education and for the professions
really essentially opened for the first
time to people outside of northern
tehran which is the most cosmopolitan
part of iran in a way where if you look
at the statistics the unesco statistics
and other you know international
statistics in terms of literacy rates
and participation of women in many
different sectors the advancement of
women over the past 30 years has been
strikingly significant inside iran I can
you know even tell you from my personal
experience of being there it's you know
you look out the window and you'll see
in a car you look out the window that
there's a woman driving a minibus so
there are women who you know there's
whose women who are ministers in the
government women who's driving a woman
who is driving a bus at the University
one of the big problems is that there
are so many women there they're
concerned that there aren't there
there's going to be such a
disproportionate number of women that
they will outnumber the men and they may
need to institute an affirmative action
trivet of action program for men it also
becomes the Islamic Republic does a lot
of very interesting things the other one
of the other interesting things it's
done is it's one of the most advanced
countries in terms of family planning
initially in the early days of the
revolution the revolutionaries
encouraged large families as part of
their needs i said for greater
population the Islamic Republic but very
soon they realized what kind of you know
the destructive aspects of this for for
Iranians for modernization and just for
the for the for the country and they
instituted a pretty comprehensive family
planning program where the country today
it's it's pretty easy to get family
planning advice and assistance and
there's also a lot of emphasis on things
that that we've come to relatively you
know well it's relatively late i think
in terms of embracing women to
breastfeed their children to have places
in the workplace to do so i often travel
with my young children and i find you
know the islamic republic is one of one
of the few places where it's easy to
bring them in there's an understanding
about women in the workplace also having
children and having this this this
balance I don't say that to say that
it's any kind of ideal place it is not
by any stretch but I don't think that
there's I don't think there are many
places that are ideal but i think this
there it is a myth that it's a really
misogynistic place there's a lot
tremendous room for improvement I think
Iranians of all genders and walks of
life are constantly working to make it a
better place there are many many areas
that need improvement but it's I think
part of a caricature that just misses a
lot of the struggle that women have in
all societies they struggle in Iran as
well but there are a lot of there have
also been some very tangible benefits
over the past past 30 years very good
let's talk a little bit about some of
the findings in your book I know it's a
bit premature and that it's it's not
completed yet but can you share some of
them with us I think the some of the the
most important findings are how
difficult it will be particularly on the
US side to really transform the
relationship to come to grips with the
Islamic Republic that it will take a
tremendous amount of almost re-education
on our parts to really come to terms
with what goes on inside the Islamic
Republic and to take a much more to take
a really sober look that their foreign
policy and national security strategy
the other pieces how how difficult it
will be to manage deal with our allies
in the region so that a realignment
between the United States and the
Islamic Republic of Iran is not
perceived as a zero-sum game against our
allies so in that regard to look at to
look at Israel to look at saudi arabia
and how to one of the important findings
is that there's a tremendous amount of
concern within Saudi Arabia within
Israel US allies of how the u.s. could
turn the relationship with Iran the
necessity to do so now the necessity to
do so takes almost two extremes the
necessity to do so is if the United
States could somehow get its act
together and figure out a way to deal
constructively with the Islamic Republic
very few people in the Middle East think
that we can do that the other extreme is
how are we then going to militarily take
care of this problem with the Islamic
Republic so that's that's the major
those are I think the major difficulties
and how the United States is going to
deal with with our allies in the region
to make any kind of realignment in
relations not a zero-sum game and so I'd
say that's probably one of the the most
disturbing most challenging findings in
the research so far as how entrenched
views are not only in the United States
but in the region in terms of how to
deal with with the rise of Iran very
thanks so much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work
thank you very much for more information
about professor Leverett and her work
please visit our website at yale edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale